أكد البنتاغون لشبكة CNN أنه كان
يجب أن يكون على علم بتسريب بيانات
قادم من أحد خوادم البريد الإلكتروني الخاصة به
قبل وقت طويل من ذلك ، فقد استغرق الأمر
أسبوعين حتى أدركت وزارة الدفاع
أن أه دفين من رسائل
البريد الإلكتروني غير السرية كانت معلقة  الإنترنت
وعندما جاء باحث الأمن السيبراني
إلى البنتاغون لتنبيههم إلى
ذلك ، كان ذلك فقط عندما اكتشفوا
ذلك الآن ، ليس من غير المألوف أن
تعرض خوادم الكمبيوتر البيانات في
المؤسسات الكبيرة ولكن هذا هو
الجيش الأمريكي وهذا الخادم لديه
رسائل البريد الإلكتروني التي تحتوي أحيانًا على بعض
المعلومات الحساسة حول المناقشات
حول
معدات الشراء وهذا النوع من
الأشياء ، لذلك هذا شيء كان البنتاغون
يحقق فيه أه
الأيام العديدة الماضية ، لكنها حقًا
المرة الأولى ليلة الخميس حيث اعترفوا
لشبكة CNN أنه كان ينبغي عليهم أن يعرفوا  حول
هذا في وقت سابق وهم يكتشفون
ما يتعين عليهم فعله فيما يتعلق
بتغيير بروتوكولات الأمن السيبراني الخاصة بهم
لعدم السماح بحدوث ذلك مرة أخرى.